sur l'air de décollage tout est cadré
millimétré pour ces championnats du
monde les conditions doivent être
parfaites hauteur des nuages météo une
fois décroché la voltige planeur exige
une concentration maximale du pilote
[Musique]
connor doit évoluer dans un carré de 1
km de long de haut et de large et il
décolle derrière un avion jusqu'à 1300
mètres et le début de la voltige
commence aux alentours de 1200 m
c'est encore plus difficile quand
l'avion parce que en avion ils peuvent
encore un peu se rattraper le moteur
temps en temps pour certaines figures
mais là le moindre écart est
immédiatement visible est sanctionné
photo avant de décoller les pilotes sont
dans leur bulle il prépare
méticuleusement leur vol
pour se préparer il faut anticiper car
une fois en vol vous lever les yeux vers
l'horizon et vous n'avez pas le temps de
lire ce papier avocat tu as ensuite ce
n'est pas un nouvel art martial les
pilotes font et refont leurs
enchaînements de figures au sol à côté
des avions en fait ils s'imaginent faire
toutes les figures qui va faire pendant
son vol et il s'attarde sur tous les
détails qu'il faut qu'ils qui prennent
en compte pendant le vol mais pour que
ce soit le plus mécanique possible il
faut vraiment le répéter longtemps dès
qu'il est dans son planeur il ya plus
d'improvisation tout est mécanique et
toucher le plus fil de ma passion
48 pilotes de 12 pays du monde sont
présents le spectacle dans le ciel
d'issoudun va durer une semaine c'est la
première fois que cette épreuve se
déroule en france et c'est déjà un
événement en soi
[Musique]